[Musik]
ich bin ja richtig gespannt darauf was
uns dieses wochenende erwartet ich auch
ich war schon viel zu lange nicht mehr
wandern
ich war vor zwei wochen mit lisa am see
das war auch schön wirklich seid ihr
auch schwimmen gegangen
nein dafür war es zu kalt aber wir haben
enten gesehen und gefüttert das sind
süße tiere
nächster halt fuhr der zug endet hier
das zog team bittet alle fahrgäste
auszusteigen und verabschiedet sich von
ihnen in der ferienregion lenzerheide
komm schon unser postbus fährt bald ab 9
uhr
jetzt geht es wirklich nach oben
stimmt ich freue mich schon auf die gute
bergluft
vielleicht ist es auch genug waren um im
see zu schwimmen hat es dort einen seh
ich habe meinen badeanzug gar nicht
eingepackt keine angst daran habe ich
gedacht und ihn für dich mitgenommen
[Musik]
gehen wir erstmal noch proviant
einkaufen
gute idee
hier gibt es produkte aus der region
tina hier sind wirklich regionale
produkte hmm das sieht alles so lecker
aus da krieg ich gleich kohldampf
das stimmt was wollen wir kaufen
dieser bergkäse sieht super aus
und diese wurst salsitz
dieses bauernbrot passt sicher gut dazu
und hier ist eine nachspeise bündner
nusstorte
super wasser finden wir sicher in einem
bergbach genau auf geht's wo die
landschaft ist hedia wirklich
unglaublich schön es ist ein paradies
schau da unten steht ein reh
sie mal auf dem see kann man auch
wakeboard fahren das würde ich gerne mal
ausprobieren
mach du das jetzt wandern wir aber
zuerst klar ich denke dabei auch an
morgen
2,5 stunden dauert die wanderung nach
unten
das steht jedenfalls auf dem wegweiser
unterwegs können wir ja ein picknick
einlegen
das wandern ist des müllers lust
es tut so gut hier zu sein
ja und dieses panorama ist überwältigend
diese nuss tor dort wirklich
ausgezeichnet geschmeckt
du hast ja auch fast die ganze torte
alleine gegessen
ich habe nicht die ganze torte gegessen
es hat noch ein gutes stück du kannst es
gerne essen
also gehen wir noch ein stückchen
vorsicht china hier kreuzen sich radweg
und wanderweg die ferien
region lenzerheide ist bekannt für ihre
bike trails da läuft im sommer fast
gleich viel wie im winter
da kommt noch ein biker hallo
jetzt ist der weg frei
hier hat es sogar noch ein bisschen
schnee das stimmt es ist aber gar nicht
kalt
nein siehst du aber wie die schatten
länger werden
es wird wohl zeit ins hotel zu gehen
lasst uns einchecken gehen
[Musik]
hallo ich habe ein doppelzimmer für eine
nacht gebucht willkommen
wie ist denn ihr name ich heiße tina
nowak und weinfreund heißt daniel smith
einen kleinen moment bitte ich schaue
nach alles klar
ihr zimmer hat die nummer 406 bitte
nehmen sie den aufzug
ich wünsche ihnen einen angenehmen
aufenthalt
das zimmer des gemütlich komm wir
duschen uns kurz ja ich will auch
frische kleider anziehen und danach
gehen wir etwas essen
[Musik]
was darf ich ihnen bringen haben sie
eine regionale spezialität
[Musik]
ich kann ihnen capus empfehlen
das kenne ich nicht was ist das das ist
ein spätzli teig mit sitz in einem
mangold platz das ganze in milch gekocht
und mit bergkäse überbacken
das versuchen wir gerne nicht war daniel
absolut das lassen wir uns nicht
entgehen
gabuns für zwei personen sehr gerne das
dauert einige minuten
ich gehe noch kurz meine zähne putzen
nach diesem tollen tag schlafe ich
sicher gut
[Musik]
nein
gefällig daniel ich habe mich extra
hübsch gemacht
diese morgenspaziergang am heize ist
super du bist gestern wirklich schnell
eingeschlafen
ja ich war hundemüde nun möchte ich das
wakeboarden einmal ausprobieren
ich habe gestern nämlich online einen
termin gebucht
ich mache ein paar fotos von dir
ich ziehe mich nur kurz um das ist in
diesem neoprenanzug lustig aus das
glaube ich
das hat spaß gemacht
das sieht man auch auf den fotos die
sind gut geworden
er hat es ja auch enden
ich möchte jetzt wissen ob das wasser
warm ist ist mir zu kalt komm wir gehen
lieber ins hallenbad
[Musik]
hier ist das wasser schön war dass
regeneriert den ganzen körper ja das
lässt mich den ganzen stress der stadt
vergessen kein büro kein chef keine
sorgen und keine hausaufgaben
oh ja
einfach nur entspannen
gehen wir zum abschluss des tages noch
einen auf einen berg ja wir können den
sessellift nehmen
am liebsten würde ich nach lengerich
bleiben musst du morgen wirklich
arbeiten
ich habe eigentlich die letzten wochen
viel gearbeitet
ich frage gleich fan ob er meine schicht
übernehmen kann
halli hallo tina hallo verwandt sagt mal
arbeitest du nächste woche fiel
nein ich habe hans vergessen zu sagen
dass sich nun doch keinen urlaub brauche
das trifft sich gut
ich würde gerne spontan eine woche
urlaub machen kannst du eine schicht
übernehmen
das ist
super das ist nett von dir
ich wünsche dir eine gute woche
das wünsche ich dir auch ich kann auch
länger bleiben
das freut mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]